[Music]
[Applause]
hey tim legler
from the mother ship here joining us on
loan from the mother ship good morning
tim
how are you good morning dan i love
bowling too i have my own bowling shoes
i bought which is weird i know but i
have a 15 and
a lot of those 15s at the bowling alleys
they're so
stretched out the velcro straps they
like slip off your feet so i bought my
own bowling shoes i love the ball
i have my own bowling shoes and i had my
own bowling ball
as well did you guys ever bowl in the
nba
no never never i love it i swear
i i could go bowling two three times a
week that's how much i love doing it
uh thanks for coming on that's all i
wanted to know tim
thanks for having me so tim is a former
uh player and one of the great shooters
in nba history if you played now
what would your career be like now as
opposed to what it was
uh i mean well first of all even even
back then if i didn't have that knee
injury i had at 29 years old you know
you tack another six seven years old to
the end of it it would look different
too
but today you know playing in this style
this system
and i'm going out there every night dan
and i'm expecting
to take six eight ten three point shots
at night
are you kidding me with that kind of
freedom mentally to take
to know that there is no such thing as a
bad three
that i could take i can't imagine like
what that would do to unleash
like just you have no inhibition and for
a great shooter to have no inhibition
whatsoever as
especially as a role player um believe
me i watch it every night i just can't
believe the freedom that these guys have
but who do you think would their career
would have changed
if they had played today let's say they
played in the 70s 80s 90s
that given this game now we we would
look at them differently
i think any of the guys that you know
were kind of like the way i played i
mean
even a guy like kerr he and i he and i
you know
battled it out we were basically the
same exact years in the league
um very similar type players can you
imagine
you know being able to come out and
knowing that they almost
expect you to shoot the ball every time
you touch it where
you know when i played it was
incomprehensible on a three-on-two birth
to fan out for a three-point shot
that's just that's just not what you did
you know you you were not
taught the game that way and i had i
felt like the green light on teams i
played on
but the green light was a different
shade of green that's what i'm saying
you still had to think through the
process
is this a good shot isn't it you knew
what the team was trying to get a lot of
the when i played was inside out we had
a bunch of great post players in
washington
that ball was going in there first
guarantee you
up the floor allow double teams to
happen the ball gets moved around the
perimeter and then
you're allowed to take the shot but some
of these shots these guys take in the
first five six seconds of the shot clock
and no one even bats an eye out and
coaches you know they clap their hands
on a miss
on a shot you know that quickly it
really blows my mind but
look i'm all for it i'm happy for the
players to have that kind of freedom i
wish i
did we've been talking about russell
westbrook's place in history his head
coach
scotty brook said he might be the second
greatest point guard of all time
we kind of lost these designations
though legs because
steph curry is not a point guard
but can i can i put him in the category
of
you know point guards no i agree with
you yes you can
i guess because of the amount of time
he's got the ball in his hands you know
as an initial
playmaker primary ball handler up the
floor that's kind of how i described
like who the point guard is
but you're right it's all blurred i mean
luka doncic
is listed as a forward right is that not
a point guard lebron james is a point
guard he's been a point guard his entire
career
and we don't call him appointment guard
so it's really about
who dominates the ball and who's the
primary
ball handler playmaker decision maker
most possessions
that would be curry but you're right i
mean they play the game
completely differently than what you and
i would have thought of a traditional
point guard
played the position like growing up but
you have magic as the greatest point
guard of all time
yes definitely no question second is
oh my goodness second it starts to get a
little bit more debatable now one of the
guys that i never got to see
play i don't know you know how much you
know
film you've seen on the guy but oscar
robertson was he a point guard because
there are people that are going to say
he's the great he's the second greatest
point guard of all time
um is it john stockton
when you look at a guy that set the
table for everybody and what he did
defensively too is john stockton the
second greatest player is it curry i
think curry has played himself now
into that position he will be labeled a
point guard historically
forever so is he i think now it's
it's not out of the question that steph
curry is in that discussion and in that
debate and by the way i know a lot of
people dan
i've debated this with that fun game
where you say okay let's draft
you take five i take five one at a time
and let's go play one game
to win and everything historically all
the players that have ever played in the
nba
if you tell me you got first pick and
you're taking magic johnson at point and
i
can't get him and i take steph curry
i'll be okay with that decision
i think i'm gonna do pretty well in that
game with steph curry as my guy at the
point in an all-time game with 10 guys
what about isaiah thomas
yeah isaiah thomas is in there as well i
think isaiah thomas
probably doesn't get as much credit as
some of the other guys particularly so
many guys the contemporary guys now
because he wasn't really an explosive
scorer unless he
absolutely had to be and right now we're
putting such an emphasis
on the three-point shot and the
eye-popping scoring numbers that these
point guards put up guys like lillard
and curry westbrook a lot of knights
that
we lose sight of what isaiah thomas was
taught that position was supposed to
look like
on any given night there's no question
one night isaiah thomas could average 25
to 30 points
if that's what he wanted to do in a
given season he didn't view it
that way that position and that team had
great balance that he played on
he's tim legler espn nba analyst did the
clippers
try to avoid the lakers probably
and i think that's why lou was so testy
about the question
but do you have any problem with that no
i don't
i don't have a problem with it at all
it's it's it's one of those things where
you can't control it you know
it's not as if there are rules in place
to prevent it there's nothing you can do
about it
just like load management just like
anything else they want
guys um to sit certain nights they have
criteria for it
how are you supposed to prevent a team
from saying oh you know what guys got a
little bit of a tight hand me tonight
groin last night you felt a little
twinge we're gonna sit him out this game
you can't
prevent it you can't call them liars
it's it's something that is very
difficult to prove it won't show up on
an mri
so you can sit guys out when you want to
and what happens at the end of the year
this is going on for a long time by the
way the manipulation of lineups at the
end of the season
for a lot of different reasons so no i
don't have a problem with it the only
problem i have with it is
what message does it send to your team
if that's what you're trying to do
so internally psychologically i got a
little bit of a problem with it because
if you think you can win it
you shouldn't care who you play when you
play them but
no i don't have a problem with it
because everyone around the league
manipulates their lineups for different
reasons yeah but i want the lakers now
tim i i just if they start getting
they start rolling then i don't want any
part of that if if i'm the suns the jazz
the clippers
let me take my shot now and see if i can
knock you out early
i completely agree and i i use the
analogy with the lakers
they're a prize fighter and you've got
to come out and you've got to catch them
with a huge hook or an uppercut
in the first 30 seconds of the fight and
if you don't
each round they're going to get stronger
and that's what's going to happen with
the lakers look they might lose
tonight wouldn't shock me you know they
haven't played together a lot here at
the end of the year lebron jd
curry's on fire warriors are playing
well not gonna be shocked if the lakers
lose
but they're not going to lose two games
in a row they're going to get in
and then they take a sigh of relief okay
we dodged
disaster now you got us in a seven
game series each game each round they
get stronger
and i expect them to be back in the nba
finals it's a weird situation
they're going to come in as a seven or
eight seed and be favored immediately
that's a very weird thing to happen in
the nba that's very unfortunate
for utah phoenix to end up getting that
team and when you had the year that you
did
as a one or two scene who has a better
chance against the lakers the clippers
the jazz the nuggets
sons i would have said well i would have
said denver but i don't know how you
overcome jamal murray not being there
and as good as michael porter is and
he's headed for stardom
and he's been unbelievable really the
last couple months can he do that
every night against that team so i don't
think he's quite
there yet for that there'll be
inconsistency there you don't have jamal
murray that's an
impossible task so i don't think it's
denver anymore i would probably say the
clippers
but there's a huge caveat and it's on
paul george's shoulders
there there's a few players going into
this postseason down with an enormous
amount of pressure on them
giannis has a lot of pressure on i think
paul george
is in that category i think james harden
is in that category
those three guys probably have more
pressure than anybody else in the
postseason because of some of their
playoff failures
paul george's seasons typically end in a
fiery crash
where he doesn't play well when they
absolutely have to have him in last
year's game seven against denver
is another example of that he had games
like that in oklahoma city
he had a couple times like that in
indiana go back and look at the last
game of paul george's season
typically not great he's got to be
big for them to have a chance but i do
think probably the talent of kawhi and
paul george
gives them the best chance against a.d
and lebron
any chance for the celtics against the
nets
i say look jason tatum's got to be the
best player on the floor in any night in
which they win
how much can you expect that out of one
guy when you're playing against
the firepower that the nets have there's
never been a collection of offenses raw
offensive talent
at the top of one roster in the history
of his league that's what you're facing
he went to the line 17 times last night
he was sensational the nets aren't going
to foul him that much
they're going to make him make more
shots than that not let him get into a
rhythm at the foul line
um and even if he is great in this
series which i think he can be
kemba walker has to be even better
probably
and he's been really good lately but is
kevin walker going to give you 25 a
night in this series
i don't think so and that's what it
would take to even win i think two games
i think it's probably a five game series
maybe the celtics get an early split we
get interested for a second at the end
of the day
i do not know how any team is supposed
to match the firepower of what those
three guys bring to the table because
they can beat you
on every platform offensively who's your
mvp
well it was embiid most of the season
but i think at the end of the day
i'm gonna pull for the guy that was
there every night and i know that's a
big part of this argument i typically
defend guys that miss a little bit of
time in fact embiid for rookie of the
year i thought it was a joke that he
didn't win it
even though he played 31 games i said
wait a second you're going to tell me
my eyes did not see joella beat as the
most dominant rookie player
that year first year player obviously he
was people thought he didn't play enough
so malcolm bragging gets rookie the year
i was against that
i'm at the point now with lebron missing
so much time and b
missing so much time hard missing so
much time they were the three guys i
think in the mix
if we're gonna reward a guy for being
there every night that also by the way
is you know 26 11 and 8
i'm all for it so i think jokic is
deserving of it and i think joking will
win it but
i thought joella embiid for 75 80
of the season was the mvp it just got to
the point he just missed a little bit
too much
time and i think joking should be
rewarded for being there every night how
many times did you face the bulls when
they had jordan pippen and rodman uh
i don't know the number of games on the
top of my head but i'll tell you this my
career
was to 1990-2000 i was in the eastern
conference
for a good part of that they won six
titles during that time
i saw more than my share of those guys
and and to this day
one of the most you know intimidating
things you faced as a player
they were the only team i ever played
against in the nba that pressed
after free throws and got away with it
when you got rodman pippen jordan ron
harper
picking you up in the backcourt in a one
two one one
trap with that kind of length it was
amazing to see point guards sort of just
run up the floor
to wave at you like yeah get it legs you
got it bring it up
uh because that first pass in the deep
corner
and you turn and you've got rodman
running at you with scottie pippen
and it was like an eclipse uh so yeah i
saw more than my share and
to this day that's the greatest
defensive team
you know that i for certainly ever
played against but i think that's the
best defensive team
i've ever seen to this day were those
mid 90s bulls teams
but the best defender out of that group
was who scottie pippen i think scottie
pippen is the best defensive player
maybe outside of bill russell and again
a guy i didn't see play but
obviously different roles scottie pippen
is the best
defender i've ever seen because he was
not only the best individual defender
he was the best team help defender as
well the ground he covered his iq
his communication his instincts combined
with
six eight fingertips touching both
sidelines
kind of a nightmare you know you came
off screens i played against him he'd
switch
jordan beyond me they'd switch on the
bass line and come off a down screen
i knew i had enough separation to get a
clean shot off because i've done it a
million times in my life
catch turn pivot turn left shoulder go
to square up and all of a sudden this
arm would come out of nowhere
and now you're going up and you're
having to make a pass in midair
that was the recover ability of scottie
pippen um
he was he was special one of a kind in
in the way that he covered ground out
there
you ever make jordan mad yes i did
because jordan loved to gamble
defensively um and so he would turn into
camel
but he was the kind of guy that you know
he'd be guarding me and obviously i
wasn't going to do
a ton off to dribble against a guy like
that so he knew kind of i was going to
spot up and wait
he loved to turn his head and oh did he
love to rake down in the post
try to go get chris webber jalon howard
rasheed wallace get those guys from
behind
when they'd make a move to the middle i
would relocate
ball would come out get some space so
yes i remember a game which i hit a
couple of threes because he turned his
head and left me and i remember after
the second or third one
running down the court and michael's
saying to me on the way down to court
well that that's it for you
i'm not leaving you again and there's
pretty much like
the equivalent of i guess the the water
company shutting your mane off
your water is shut off right now and
that's that's kind of how you felt
um so at that point we're gonna have to
get it in transition
you know if michael is picking up
somebody else if that's what you want
isn't that amazing
he's telling you your night's done and
you know
that he's right yeah and you know what
if you're making threes against michael
jordan you know what i kind of felt like
hey that's okay i already had my night
man
he's against you but uh you know he he
actually it's funny i have a picture in
my house and he and i are
standing next to each other it's kind of
cool this is 23 23 our backs jordan
legler we're talking each other i got a
little smirk on my face we're talking
and somebody said
oh you know what's that jordan talking
trash to you and i said no actually that
was the first
game i played after the three-point
shootout in san antonio when i won it we
played chicago on the road the very
first game after that
and actually and my daughter was born
that week my first child they made a big
story about that
all-star weekend when i won it and he
was actually asking me about that
he was like hey you know get home and
see that little girl congratulated me on
winning the three-point shootout
and that's what that picture captured i
just got lucky someone happened to take
that picture at that time
um and it's a pretty cool thing so
obviously the greatest of all time that
nothing's ever going to change my mind
about that because i saw it up close and
personal too personal
uh seeing that team as many times as i
did in the 90s but
uh that was a cool cool moment for me
because it showed you the humanity of
michael jordan as well and his awareness
of kind of like what was going on and
for a guy like me that that was a year
which i had a breakout year and it was
that was a national moment for me
for michael jordan to recognize that was
pretty cool leg's great to talk to you
as always thanks for the stories
thanks there you go that's tim legler
espn nba
analyst